THURSDAY FEBRUARY THIRD IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. PLEASE READ
ADVISER AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEED IS
BEING MADE IT IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ATTEND THIS HEARING MUST WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES ATTENDEES MUST
ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT THIS
HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES MAY SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL
TO REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. OF MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HERE I
HAVE THAT HERE BONTA LARA GET
THEM HERE WE YEAH MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS RAMOS YEAH HERE WE HAVE
THE LOCK HERE. BOB WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA. IS OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA. OVER MISTER GIBSON'S
FROM LEE SIR PLEASE GO THE ROLL
. I YEAH AND IT. HI FIVE THE
FLOOR DEFENSE ARE DIFFERENT
HIGHLY HI WE MAIENSCHEIN I CAN'T
FIND. MATHIS GONNA FIVE. I RUBIO
HI RUBIO WHAT PART OF OUR. IF
YOU HAPPEN TO PASSED OF ARE IS A
IN THE CHAMBER FOR OUR REMAIN A
MINUTE FRIEDMAN FOR YEAH THERE'S
A AT YOUR TO OF THE CHAIN. YES.
WHERE A CONSENT AGENDA MATHIS
FIVE MATHIS HI VERY GOOD- THE
MOTION IS PASSED AND THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. YOUR.